transgender movement in its ideology
it's
anti-feminist it's inconsistent with an
ecological worldview and it's also
intellectually
incoherent and what I mean by that is
not you know an insult it's that if you
actually read trans literature and try
to make sense of it I find it impossible
to do so there's no consistent
definition of what transgender is
there's no even attempt to understand
the ideology or the causes right the the
thing that I find most striking is at
this point the transgender movement says
we are normal there's nothing
pathological about being transgendered
but at the same time it
demands uh access to medical care
including medical care that that
interferes with normal human development
through puberty blockers for children um
and so it's both entirely normal yet a
condition that needs medical treatment